so I have been teaching architecture in
the Graduate School of Architecture
since 2000 and I started to do a project
that i'm going to show you while i was
teaching seminars and studios in
architecture we teach two types of
courses one is a studio course the other
is a seminar course the studio courses
is basically a course where you learn
the technique of architectural design
but you also you also do more
exploratory or analytical type projects
i also am in a practitioner of
architecture i have a practice with a
partner and our offices in Long Island
City so I teach but I also build things
so the project that I'll show is an
installation it was at the studio museum
in Harlem in 2004 in a show called
harlem world and and i saw that the book
harlem world was on your reading list
yeah so the show was it kind of took
that title was called Hollen world
metropolis is metaphor and I developed
this project in response to the
invitation to participate in the show
but then I also developed the project
from a paper that I had written earlier
which was called black bodies black
space awaiting spectacle and that space
that that paper dealt with the way that
black bodies are positioned in space and
how they're they're kind of spectacular
rise so it's a condition of vision one
where the black body is recognized first
by sight and then is kind of
sensationalized as
result and when I wrote this paper for
me as an architect it was very easy to
draw off of cultural criticism literary
criticism post-colonial criticism but it
was hard to draw off of architecture
criticism so the paper ended with the
question of the city the idea of the
black city and that's the project I'll
show okay i'm going to show two things
first which which are these demographic
maps this is maybe you know this site
social explorer it's by a professor at
Queens College and these are maps that
show the development like migration in
the city over time so this is New York
this is a map of migrations of the white
population in New York from 1910 to 2000
and this kind of map was a resource it
draws from census files and then it
pictorial eise's movements in space so
it's a kind of great tool this one is
the movement of whites and this is the
movement of the black population and
usually with these maps that map black
and white populations they tend to be
the inverse so the negative of one is
the positive of the other
ok so anyway so this kind of is a little
bit of a background for the way oops I
approach the project i'm going to show
the installation and i'll talk over it
it's about 12 or 13 minutes this video
it's called the black city and it's
cited in harlem but harlem is only one
of the city's the black city could be
any city in the united states and i
started with Harlan so the installation
begins with the idea of of the black
city as a kind of psychic phenomenon and
it moves toward the idea of the black
City the reality of it as a physical
phenomenon and the project bridges
between the two the the kind of lived
condition and the almost like I don't
know like supra normative condition like
something that's in the mind or
something that's kind of symbolic or
even felt so basically I'm not going to
read the text i'll just talk around the
text and explain it but i will stop here
so this is a really important diagram
for the project which basically explains
the whole logic of it and the
installation unpacks the diagram but
i'll just talk about it a little bit
they're actually two ideas of the city
in this project one is the idea of the
black city as a as an exploration of the
dynamics and concepts that are that
shape the the reality that black people
live in so it's that that clear an idea
of the black city but it's also just a
kind of condition of blackness as
this where you don't have to be black to
inhabit that space and what I've done in
this project you won't see images
because I very much have fought against
using images kind of stereotypical
images of black people and very often in
architecture projects or other projects
a black person is kind of put in the
project to sort of symbolize that
there's a social sensitivity and it
doesn't necessarily mean that the
project is socially sensitive but the
body they're kind of gives it the aura
that it is and so I was very much trying
to work with what was underneath the
images so i started with images and i
was trying to get at the the operative
elements below the images so the black
bodies in this project are represented
by census statistics and the statistics
kind of are showing at different scales
so there's a scale of the world to the
united states united states to New York
New York to Harlem and the project is
about zooming in to Harlem looking at
the the sort of systems that that it's a
part of
so I should let it play more right so
this is basically an idea that the black
city is framed within statistics and is
affected by policies which are implicit
and explicit things like laws or
cultural codes or or mores and then this
this image is just really about whoops
where I started so the project started
with the literary idea of the black city
and these are all the different names
for Harlem that I could find in literary
work so they're kind of they present
this mythic image of Harlem from the
positive to the negative and then these
are this kind of statistical image of
Harlem which is very dry and it's it's
all based on data so it has to do with
demographics statistics that that kind
of map the development of different
groups of people and compare them
relative to each other so i was using
GIS statistics which is geographical
information systems that are tied into
the census statistics to give an image
to the data so when you fill out a
census because you have an address all
of the data is keyed into the address
but again I was not really wanting to
show geography everything is shown more
abstract so it's just on a grid what
these are our the census tables that I
actually used for the different areas to
visualize
the concepts these are concepts of the
black city and this one deals with the
concept of minorities and typically in
statistical charts minorities are
represented with pie charts and so part
of what I'm doing is playing with the
representation of the statistics at the
same time that I'm visualizing them so
I'm trying to spatial eyes the
statistics
okay so actually part of the show is
missing but what you're seeing here is
the concept of white flight and the
corresponding concept black belt which
do deal with the migration of blacks and
whites so similar to the social explorer
maps that I showed in the beginning that
kind of show the movement of people
across the United States that's what
what these are our mapping and they end
up being inverses of each other so when
I started this project I I kind of began
in a way from a social sciences
perspective but without really having
any grounding in the social sciences but
I was curious about terms like upward
mobility glass ceiling black belt white
flight their terms that are used to
explain concepts that are also
represented in statistics and what I was
what I was wondering was whether the
statistics came first or the concept
like was there this phenomenon that
people wanted to talk about and that
they had to find a new phrase or word to
encapsulate it you know did the data
come first or the concept
this one is a map of university
enrollment and incarceration rates and
it was not surprising to me to find that
for blacks and whites their inverse of
each other but to see it makes it
palpable so one of the things that I
wanted to do and that I'm still working
on is making the effects visible to the
public and to make them something that
by making them visible making them
something that it might be easier to
talk about so this talks about the two
aspects of the black city that it's a
live condition it end that it exists but
that it's a condition that doesn't
really exist and that the people who
inhabit it are kind of invisible and i'm
playing with notions like Richard
Wright's concept of the invisible man
when I write things like that so this
part of the installation Maps the
dynamics of the black city and i
conceive the black that the dynamics as
the field oxalates it's like the field
that we all operate in so it's the field
that shapes everything and it's it's the
the field of the power structure and so
it's characterized by certain dynamics
which have to do with migrating and
mixing policing and displaying these are
these are characteristics that seem to
me to really be critical in any
discussion of the black city like the
aspect of of criminalization the aspect
of movement and migration and mixing and
fear of mixing their kind of key
characteristics of the city
in contrast to the dynamics of the city
which are everything around you the
field that you know you're sort of
brought into when you you enter the
world there are tactics or techniques
that are employed by people who don't
operate who don't have the power within
that system and they they sort of
operate within it but also kind of
against it or alongside it and so this
aspect of the project is is kind of
informed by the discourse about other
pneus when it comes to things like
language so black language for example
there's the quote about signifying and
the work of Henry Louis Gates on the
signifying monkey but also the work of
other theorists michele de certeau on
patois and how in kind of corrupting a
language the people who who adopt a
foreign language make it their own so
they kind of transform it by corrupting
it and make it their own and so these
are basically 12 techniques and they
they're kind of techniques that are used
in jazz we're used in jazz used in the
blues used in language playing ways of
disrupting an existing structure and
inverting it and making it your own I
was really interested in the the aspect
of oh what well in signification there's
the aspect of dazzling display right so
one of the characteristics of the black
city is is always being cited or
identified by sight so the idea of the
dazzling display the display that just
stuns and and is so overpowering which
to me seems to be a really integral part
of
african american and other cultures i
was kind of trying to work with that
idea in the project so all the images
that you're seeing are very abstract and
kind of even for architecture abstract
they don't look like shapes that you've
seen and I was trying very much to not
have it look like shapes that I knew to
not make it look like buildings because
it's not forming buildings its forming
the forces behind the buildings the
forces behind the social structure
so my project in doing this is actually
the black city squared which is the
inversion or interruption and reframing
of the black city in the hopes that in
the process there might be new new
techniques which could be architectural
or urban techniques that could like from
an architect's perspective that could
help help reframe an architectural
discourse or an architectural practice
so the images you see are like to me
science fiction fantasy images and
that's a large part of it but it's this
idea of different things not different
but very specific things coming together
like for instance in the studio that I
taught this is the end of the images the
students looked at not just Harlem they
looked at Miami Chicago New Orleans
different cities and we analyzed the
dynamics of those cities and things that
the students were looking at were much
more specific than what I looked at so I
had done this project and it became a
base that the students worked off of so
a student in New York was looking at red
hook and she looked at the red lining
process of you know mortgage mortgage
lending in the city and the development
of neighborhoods based on unlike
redlining or redistricting for voting
and the way that people are kind of
positioned in the city and sort of
restricted from moving or allowed to
move based on these types of policies so
working with the students it was
actually really interesting because they
while I wanted the project to be much
more abstract they wanted things to be
more concrete so so we worked with very
like it was actually very helpful for me
we worked with much more
concrete realizations of of like say the
the idea of migration or or of policing
a student looked at policing in terms of
surveillance cameras in the city and
where you can get maps of where
surveillance cameras are and what she
found which was a surprise to her was
that the cameras are actually trained
more on objects than people and that
based on the way that the cameras are
positioned in the city it's obvious that
our culture values objects over people
so I don't know so it's kind of an
interesting process where sometimes
you're surprised by the result that you
get and other times you you sort of know
what you're going to get um you know
when you begin in any way thank you
um doorways and actually the
neighborhood's they were trained on the
neighborhoods where the money was so
they weren't where I think what she
expected was that they were they were
crime prevention measures you know that
that they would be there to sort of map
the people who were I don't know
susceptible to to be criminals or
whatever but but actually it was much
more about where the money was and and
sort of securing it and so in places
where the crime rate was high there
weren't necessarily cameras in those
places there were cameras in places that
were safer than like the high-risk
places
said you were trying to get away from
shapes of buildings
yeah that's a good question i'm one of
the limits this of this model is that
the shapes but i had a kind of model in
mind there's a there's an MIT science
model that looks at phenomena like
boiling or it looks at it looks at like
the flow dynamic flows flows of people
flows migrations like flocking of birds
it it's this kind of software that maps
flows and I kind of used that as a model
for how I could realize these dynamics
and then so that was one idea this the
software but then as it got realized i
was using a software called Maya and so
the images are actually limited by the
limitations of the software and now I
think I could use a different software
and sort of you know make slightly
different images but that's a problem
with us
um yeah well the movements that's a good
question all the movements occur on a
grid and so the way that the techniques
which are what I started with were
designed was that they started with the
definition of the word so appropriate go
to Oxford English Dictionary look up the
word appropriate and when you look up
the meaning of the word actually I've
done a few projects like this with the
word and words and I look for the verb
form of the word because it's an action
so the action is something that can be
translated into an action in
three-dimensional software programming
so I move from a cultural definition to
something which is more of an
mathematical definition because it's an
action and so then I program that into
the computer and so the way it moves is
actually a result of the action of the
word yeah so on the grid each of the
squares has a value and things happen
you know the value shift depending on
the action
yes
compared to slide down the first one is
black signifying
yeah okay so um the idea of black
signifying I really got from the essay
the signifying monkey and looking at you
know just the the kind of tales of the
signifying monkey on the one hand but
then also the patois example um is the
other where we're through a kind of
gamesmanship um there's there's this
game of like one-upmanship so I say
something you say something that kind of
like you know raises the stakes on what
I say kind of like makes me rethink what
I say or kind of turns it over and
reforms what I say and that's kind of
the idea behind the techniques in the
black city so it's the idea that there
might be techniques that could be
employed that could if you don't have
very much power that could be employed
to empower you you know as a way of
subverting a dominant order the reason I
I kind of moved in that direction was
that in architecture there's always
there's a discourse in architecture
about blackness and architecture and
what where black architects are first of
all said to not exist um and they do and
they have for some time so they don't
exist there's no precedent they have no
history and this this kind of discourse
is often combated with a kind of retreat
to aesthetics but it's in my mind is
somewhat shallow retreat to aesthetics
on the the basis of surfaces
so some practitioners try to make things
that look black or look african and i
think you can see that i was very much
trying not to do that maybe to a fault
trying not to do that so what I was
interested in in signification is that
it's a strategy it's it's like a it's
not a form it's something that you could
employ it's not a form it's a method and
I was looking for methods because
methods you can they can take any shape
and so so it wouldn't just be about what
something look like and you know
whatever that was could change it would
be about how it acted how it performed
who are the actors well in in the black
City it's the inhabitants because
everything is sort of based on them as
numbers so every person you me were all
kind of a number we're in some data bank
we're in multiple data banks actually
and and we're represented that way we're
represented as numbers but then we're
also represented as you know forms so
that was kind of where that came from
and the idea of valuation is very much
part of that it's just the idea that but
there are different types of values in
architecture we deal with we tend not to
deal so much with social value some
architects do I think more now
architects are dealing with social value
because in the world that we live in you
can't not deal you know after September
11th and Katrina you have to deal with
social things but
but it's kind of a week discourse in
architecture it has a history though in
the same way that African American
architects have a history there's a
history of like social valuation or
social values in architecture yes the
architects deal with political economy
of urban spaces and the reason I'm
asking that is because um one of the
things we found in the class is that
Harlem is described as the most
significant of black urban space in the
world but it would be interesting to
compare Harlem as a black urban space to
the percentage of property or land real
estate that black people actually owned
in Harlem or overtime right and just do
a grid of so that this is so-called
black urban space how black is it if you
don't own it number one or a percentage
of black owned businesses in Harlem
overtime say from 1932 2007 that would
be kind of injured no architects
actually look at who owes the buildings
and the ownership how that drives space
utilization and what happens to the
population in the so-called black City
yeah actually I'm I think that should be
something I I add ownership because if
yeah because I'm like who has the rights
to you know the space and I mean
definitely in Harlem there's a
disjuncture between the like power of
the place based on image and it's kind
of
um Harlem if you just get books which
maybe you've done just looking up like
literary works on harlem it's it's
amazing just you can it exists as a
literary sort of cultural City but then
it exists as a physical city as well and
so kind of what what dr. marble you're
bringing up is is the like physical the
disjunction between the physical and
maybe cultural literary literary and
they overlap and they may be mask each
other like the the image of Harlem kind
of mass the real base of the power who
has the power there but by often it I
don't know like isn't that part of the
dynamic to sort of mask who has the
power and exactly I mean one of the
things I received about a year ago one
of these books that i hain't which says
these are the hundred most important
black people in US history you know like
how can you prove Dubois should be
number three kenya's number one Garvey's
number 21 who cares no right you can
never prove it anyway so there are these
books I got one of these books of the
hundred people forty one of the 100 or
arla lights that's astonishing that
means that nearly half of whoever
organized this book said that harlem on
people born or raised in Arlen or who
are identified with our Malcolm was not
born or any who's born in Omaha Nebraska
but he's a Harlem life right he's
identified with our Malcolm Charlie
Rangel of a difficult Junior Marcus
Garvey you
go through the list it is astonishing so
that you have more than any other black
community on earth the stellar group of
women and men in politics and in
aesthetics in literature and it almost
never happens that way in these two
fields who defined so much right and yet
you have this anomaly we're in the same
neighborhood black people don't own
anything right who owns the real estate
who owns the property who owns the
businesses and so this requires some
explanation that's the only point out of
it and what is it and what is the
significance of that so that to a
certain extent people are disempowered
curiously by their prominence in a way
you know
so you have a kind of neo-colonial
situation where you have like black
representation very prominent black
people black folk on 125th but both of
the stuff is still by tomor it's not all
that difference in the 1920s and 30s
although now it seems that um well the
the kind of image of Harlem as a kind of
black mecca's like somewhat shifting
because the reality is is that it's um
mixing a lot more yes so the ownership
is actually living there as opposed to
living elsewhere that's right well you
have puppies and gentrification yeah and
everything else any final questions
and was this that kind of grid with yeah
well um yeah that was a kind of
catalogue of values and it that's sort
of the part that I'm still working on
it's the idea that there are infinite
values and that values are many things
like um they could be it's a way that
surfaces are marked tag right but
materially so they're they're kind of
that that matter has cultural
significance but that depending on where
it's placed it might be read differently
so so the idea of of that catalog is
that there would be a bank of surfaces
that could be applied in the city and
depending on where they were they might
be valued differently so thank you